GoOoOoOOOOood morning gamers
it's another beautiful day
in minecraft
and today we have
a lot of lot of epic stuff to do
im actually recording this intro
after the video
because i forgot to
make one (giggles)
so first off, i've been cheating on you guys
i live streamed yesterday because i need wither skulls
our goal in this series right now, our number one priority
is to breed our pig army >:)
and to make it as strong as possible
then what we're going to do is
we're gonna make our pigs fight one of the bosses of minecraft, the wither
now to kill (*make) the wither, you need three
(big brain) uh skull thingies
which drops in the nether
i played yesterday on the live stream
and let's just cut to that footage
PAUSE
just to give you guys a summary of what happened
i enchanted my axe and was crazy lucky and got a great enchantment
woah :o
damn (bad word smh) sksksk
then i enchanted my sword and was even more lucky
sharpness 3, sweeping edge 3, fire aspect 2
i think that's pretty good
that's already so GOOD
(laughs in minecraft) alright
then there wither skull which has a 5.5 percent chance of dropping
drops on the first spawns
thats pretty smart to put it in a hallway
(GASP) :O
woah, woah, im so lucky dude
already
and if that wasn't enough
it dropped another one right after
oh my gawd
dude
looting three baby
im a lucky boy, this live stream was lucky boy
then pig explosion thing happened
pigman get out of the way
OH PIGMAN, PIIIGMAN :((
then I got a third one
Come on, Bring it
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
YEAAAAAAH!
then i got a fourth one!
Oh my god
Then I built this ugly spawner
This spawner is gonna work so good
When I wake up tomorrow
Daaamn
Dude I'm gonna get so much items
Daamn
Just wait until tomorrow, you guys criticized my spawner
Just wait until tomorrow,
like, you're gonna feel awful
This is gonna work? Yea, this is gonna work.
* MEME REVIEW *
Tomorrow when I wake up
I'm gonna have so much stuff dude
And that's where the livestream ended
Ooh, you hear that?
Time to check the che-
Wow! I got the scaffold...
How could this possibly have failed?
Hi guys, I guess you di-
AH NO
Okay, alright
Alright, alright
I guess they didn't die?
* INHALES HEAVILY *
Wow, look at that, yea
Oh look, I have new friends in boat
Hello new friends in boat
AH, how does that make any sense?
Stop friends in-
Stop friends in boat
Oh he's shooting his friend in his friend boat
Oh no you're on fire now
Alright we're going together now
I don't care what you think about me, we're gonna be friends
Just go in there
* IKEA BIRD :( *
HE KILLED IKEA BIRD!
YOU!
COME BACK HERE!
HE KILLED IKEA BIRD >:(
Once I'm through with you, you're gonna feel the pleasure-
the pain- the pleasure of pain
Oh my god, stop
I hate you!
Say your last sorry
Ikea bird...
(Ikea bird memories)
The parrot!
Oh my god it's so cute
Here I'll give you my seed
Oh, you like that?
Or that you dislike it
HE'S SITTING
Is he sitting?
He's blue too
Yes, YES, Y E S
That's so awesome!
...Was like father to me...
How could this happen?
It hurts
It really does
AHH
Water sheep
Oh gracious water sheep, why does everyone I love die?
Oh my gosh
NO, not-
NOO
Oh okay he's fine, he's fine
How do you make pants in minecraft?
Oh man it's so expensive
UGH
So as you can tell, it's getting very expensive to keep up this beautiful diamond armor,
so what you can do in minecraft,
is that you can make a villager into a librarian
But what's even better, is if you cure a villager, and if you remember, if you watch series epicly,
which of course you have
This is intense
Yo they got villagers
Apparently you can cure them
We have one of those
We need to prepare for the wither as best as we can
Okay, so to cure a villager we need one golden apple,
my gosh, expensive
And a potion of weakness
For that we need a fermented
EW
Fermented spider eye
Brown mushroom and sugar
How do we make sugar-
YOU CAN MAKE SUGAR IN MINECR-
From sugar canes, okay
Alright, that makes sense
Hey, remember when I had a sugar cane farm and then I said I don't need that anymore
Oh okay thank god I saved some
Is my spawner working?
Oh my gosh there's so many of them there that's awesome
I feel like there has to be
There has to be mushrooms in the mines somewhere
Oh my gosh there is diamond here?
Hahaha! What? (you never played-)
How did i not see this?
Oh!
OH!
I guess i haven't really showed, like, my mining area
It's not that interesting, that's why
I tried to make a spawner here...
But they are poison spiders, which is just obnoxious to even try and do anything with
Come on mushrooms, there has to be, there has to be...
Where is the mushroom?
Hello, have you seen mushroom?
OOOH, kill before....Explosion!
Pro minecrafter, gamer, yeah...
* in gothenburg * damn it Roffan, hurry your ass
hey Roff-man
come on then
come on- there we have it
* Cute japonese noises *
ROFFE!
COME ON THEN ROFFE!
here we go
Can I put a leash on him?
Or maybe?... Golden apple
I need that.
Maybe a fishing rod.
Alright, your're coming with me Rolf.
Look he is wearing a little hat.
That's so cute.
You are so cute, Rolf.
Oh my gosh!
He loves boats!
That's your favorite thing Rolf.
Look at him go!
He loves to-
He just wants to go in water.
That's so nice!
When its actually harder to find mushrooms than diamonds.
I think we have a problem.
Are you scared Rolf?
This will be the first time you see sunlight.
WOW!
(Laughter)
(Gasp), Joergen
Damn, there's so many Joergans here.
(mutters) Not the black one.
Too bad it's dead.
This is nice 'cause I can overlook my area as well, except that eyesore.
I'm gonna give it one more try.
Lure III, okay that has to be it.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
GET AWAY FROM HIM!
You have your own bed.
Oh, I got a book, I got a book!
Impaling. Silk touch! That's pretty good.
That's what I wanted to do.
Could you use a dispenser in a fishing rod?
Is there an automatic fish farm?
I'm sure someone's figured that out.
NO!
NO!!
NOO!!!
YOU SCUMBAG! YOU ABSOLUTE DEGENERATE!
HE'S SHOOTING MY TURTLES!
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
The babies, they hatched!
They all hatched!
UGHHH! What is wrong with people?
Just shooting turtles!
Okay, luckily, it looks like most of them made it.
Oh my god, so many! They're so-- haha they're so cute!
Look at this, Sven!
(laughter)
okay we just gotta keep fishing
and then we will eventually grow up and will finally
finally have
the helmet
so we can breathe underwater
Oh! It's raining
dangit
if we had the trident we could transform everyone right now
Damnit! That would have been so good
since its raining we have a little roof its so cozy
heh! Honestly it's
awesome
right Sven?
you keeping warm?
come on give me good loot
lowkey this is so cozy
(laughter)
just me and my boy fishing
so I gotta keep an
eye on the babies because when they grow up they'll drop the scute
that's all I need
oh man I forgot, I think you can feed them
yeah, yeah, yeah  you feed them, oh thats how you make them grow
how am I feeding this tiny little things?
oh my g- are you okay?
are you okay? Is you k?
you can barely see the babies but they're there
(GASP)
I got one I got a scute!
I finally got one!
(ANOTHERGASP)
they're growing
O he grew up right infront of me
O- i keep hearing
huh YeS!
how many (GASP)
oh my god how man- how many do i need?
this guys a slow
slow grower thats fine
so was I there is no shame
just because my pp got hair later, there is no shame about that
no shame AT all
Oh My GOsh I got them all
how many I got? I got 10
I got 10 baby keep fricking
don't make me stop you
11 and they ain't ever stop
so now I think if we do like a normal helmet
oh
my
gOd
yeSs
at last
finally
turtle helmet
is mine
ohhoh
teenAgE muTanT ninJa TurtLes
it matches my glasses so good
you like it Sven?
(woOf)
he loves it
do you like it?
(WaF)
thank you
I worked hard to get it
look so now I have the b- bubble enchantment on my top right
actually I should enchant this right away
(EPICENCHANTMENTNOISE)
Aqua inFINITY!
dyaamm
damn look how long I can stay underwater now thanks to the helmet
so apparently if I do this
right?
I should be able to grab it
it will just take a loonngg time
never mind it didn't take long at all
do I have it?
did I actually just place a torch on the water because I-
hahahah
BiG BrAiN
oh it went up didn't it?
there it is
I feel like i'm finally umm getting pretty good at minecraft
(laughter)
alright I think i'm gonna end that episode there I've been playing forever
and I have to edit this now as well
(laughter of pain) oh my god
there's one thing I wanna do before then
hey there
how are you?
you want some food?
black jeorgen
I forgot how you tame a hor- oh he kicked me off
ah
(GASP) HE LOVES ME :O
black jeorgen
i'll take good care of you I promise
jeorgen no no no black jeorgen please
uh.
come
welcome home buddy
welcome home...
alright cow hit it
this is not really the song but whatever
alright guys thanks for watching another episode hope you guys enjoyed smash like if you did
check out merch if you wanna support the channel and whatever
be EPIC
I really appreciate it thank you
and uhh next episode
we're gonna try
and get
the trident
so we can turn this pig army into an actual army
that's it for me for now
see ya later gamers
(epic outro)